[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deux mauvaises nouvelles mon permis est
annulé annulation des pertes du permis
j'ai plus de points et tout machin reste
une galère mais c'est de ma faute il
faut respecter le code de la route donc
si jamais vous me croisez à pied
n'hésitez pas à me prendre ce top et si
jamais vous me croisez en bonne voiture
sans permis c'est pas l'alcool ok ça n'a
rien à voir c'est juste que j'ai plus de
permis deuxième mauvaise nouvelle koh
lanta revient dans quinze jours c'est
très énervant que vous faites ça c'est
très énervant ok koh-lanta c'est une
fois par semaine un donc un jour c'est
quoi ces dix ans dans quatre jours la
6e' mardi soir le truc qui à mardi c'est
nul je vous jure je prends l'avion je
vais sur l'île de koh lanta regarder en
live ce qui se passe dans quinze jours
dans quinze jours
les amis regardez ce que j'ai trouvé le
gasoil a un euro vers celle championne
du monde vous pouvez venir en prendre le
seul souci c'est que
il ya pas la pompe mais et or aux mains
je suis là pour trouver les bons plats
j'en veux pas je dis bon même temps
qu'il en soit
c'est pourquoi batman il aime faire des
safaris en afrique parce qu'ils aiment
la bruce wayne
car depuis cette date pour toi c'est
quoi le point commun entre la poste et
le café non je ne sais pas ses torts
parce que torréfacteur
je sais comment faire pour éliminer le
dernier variant du coronavirus faut le
mettre au micro ondes
c'est quoi le deuxième nom de la
césarienne non une nourrice parce que ça
vous la mer en deux